let's take a look at subword-based
tokenization
understanding why subway-based
tokenization is interesting requires
understanding the flaws of word-based
and character-based tokenization
if you haven't seen the first videos on
word-based and character-based
tokenization
we recommend you check them out before
looking at this video
support based tokenization lies in
between character-based
and word-based tokenization algorithms
the idea is to find a middle ground
between very large vocabularies
a large quantity of out-of-vocabulary
tokens and a loss of meaning across very
similar words
for word-based tokenizers and very long
sequences as well as
less meaningful individual tokens for
character-based tokenizers
these algorithms rely on the following
principle frequently used words should
not be split into smaller sub-words
while rare words should be decomposed
into meaningful supports
an example is the word dog we would like
to have our tokenizer to have a single
id for the word dog
rather than splitting it into characters
d o and g
however when encountering the word dogs
we would like our tokenizer to
understand that at the root
this is still the word dog with an added
s that slightly changes the meaning
while keeping the original idea
another example is a complex word like
tokenization
which can be split into meaningful sub
words
the root of the word is token and
ization completes the root to give it a
slightly different meaning
it makes sense to split the word into
two token
as the root of the word labeled as the
start of the word
and isation as additional information
labeled as a completion of the word
in turn the model will now be able to
make sense of token in different
situations
it will understand that the words token
tokens tokenizing and tokenizations
have a similar meaning and are linked it
will also understand that tokenization
modernization and immunization which all
have the same suffixes
are probably used in these same
syntactic situations
subword based tokenizers generally have
a way to identify which tokens are a
start of word
and which tokens complete start of words
so here token as the start of a word and
hash hashization as completion of a word
here the hash prefix indicates that
isation
is part of a word rather than the
beginning of it
the hash comes from the bird tokenizer
based on the word piece
algorithm other tokenizers use
other prefixes which can be placed to
indicate part of words
like seen here or start of words instead
there are a lot of different algorithms
that can be used for separate
tokenization
and most models obtaining
state-of-the-art results in english
today
use some kind of subword tokenization
algorithms
these approaches help in reducing the
vocabulary sizes
by sharing information across different
words having the ability to have
prefixes and suffixes
understood as such they keep meaning
across very similar words by recognizing
similar tokens making them up